OF "THE FIVE" ."
"SPECIAL REPORT" IS UP NEXT.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP
ANNOUNCED A THREE WEEK DEAL THIS
AFTERNOON, CONGRESS IS AT THIS
HOUR WORKING ON LEGISLATION
PASSING BOTH CHAMBERS.
MIKE EMANUEL IS ON CAPITOL HILL
TO TELL US WHERE THE FUNDING
PROCESS IS BUT WE START WITH
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS AND THE PRESIDENT
PULLING THE PLUG AFTER FIVE FULL
WEEKS OF THE SHUTDOWN WITH NO
MONEY FOR HIS BORDER WALL.
>> REACTION FROM REPUBLICANS TO
THE PRESIDENT'S DEAL IS MIXED,
SOME ARE APPLAUDING THE MOVE AND
OTHERS BELIEVED THE PRESIDENT
CAVED.
THE BOTTOM LINE TONIGHT, THE
PRESIDENT COMES AWAY FROM THE
SHUTDOWN WITH LITTLE MORE THAN
HE HAD GOING INTO IT.
>> POLITICAL PRESSURE THAT HAD
BEEN BUILDING FOR WEEKS AT THE
BREAKING POINT THIS MORNING WHEN
FEDERAL WORKERS MISSED A SECOND
PAYCHECK AND AT
LaGUARDIA AIRPORT HALTED
FLIGHTS BECAUSE OF AN AIR
TRAFFIC CONTROL SHORTAGE.
WITHIN HOURS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS IN THE ROSE GARDEN
ANNOUNCING THE GOVERNMENT WOULD
SOON BE OPEN AGAIN ALBEIT
TEMPORARILY.
>> President Trump: IN A SHORT
WHILE, I WILL SIGN A BILL TO
OPEN OUR GOVERNMENT FOR 3 WEEKS
UNTIL FEBRUARY 15TH.
I WILL MAKE SURE THAT ALL
EMPLOYEES RECEIVE THEIR BACKPAY
VERY QUICKLY OR AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
IT WILL HAPPEN FAST.
>> NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERSHIP KICKED INTO HIGH GEAR
YESTERDAY, BUT AFTER INSISTING
THAT ANY DEAL TO REOPEN
GOVERNMENT HAD TO INCLUDE MONEY
FOR A BORDER WALL, THE ONE THE
PRESIDENT TOOK GAVE HIM NOTHING
EXCEPT A PLEDGE FROM DEMOCRATS
TO TRY TO REACH AN AGREEMENT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS AGREED TO
OUR REQUEST TO OPEN THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE DEBATE BORDER
SECURITY.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE INSISTS IT
HAS STRONG SIGNALS FROM LARGE
NUMBERS OF DEMOCRATS THAT THEY
ARE WILLING TO GIVE SOME FUNDING
FOR A BORDER BARRIER, LIKELY NOT
$5.7 BILLION.
HOUSE SPEAKER IS ON RECORD
SAYING THE PRESIDENT IS GETTING
NOTHING.
>> WE'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR ON THE
WALL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS MADE IT
CLEAR THE NATION COULD BE RIGHT
BACK WHERE WE STARTED.
>> President Trump: IF WE
DON'T GET A FAIR DEAL FROM
CONGRESS, THE GOVERNMENT WILL
EITHER SHUTDOWN ON FEBRUARY 15TH
AGAIN OR I WILL USE THE POWERS
AFFORDED TO ME UNDER THE LAWS
AND THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES TO ADDRESS THIS
EMERGENCY.
>> THE OFFICE OF MANAGEMENT AND
BUDGET HAS IDENTIFIED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT COULD BE
REDIRECTED TOWARD CONSTRUCTION
OF THE WALL, BUT AN EMERGENCY
DECLARATION WOULD BE IMMEDIATELY
CHALLENGED IN THE COURTS LEAVING
THE PRESIDENT WITH NO OPTIONS.
DEMOCRATS TODAY WARNED HIM
AGAINST SHUTTING DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT AGAIN.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DO NOT
LIKE IT WHEN YOU THROW A WRENCH
INTO THE LIVES OF GOVERNMENT
WORKERS OVER UNUNRELATED
POLITICAL DISPUTE.
HOPEFULLY NOW THE PRESIDENT HAS
LEARNED HIS LESSON.
>> NEGOTIATIONS WILL FALL TO A
BIPARTISAN CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
WHOSE MANDATE IS DEFINED --
BASICS REPUBLICANS WILL OPERATE
IN GOOD FAITH.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
PARTIES TO WORK TOGETHER FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR BEAUTIFUL,
WONDERFUL NATION.
>> THE DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP
COULDN'T HELP BUT TWEAK
PRESIDENT TRUMP AT SAYING HE
TRIED BUT FAILED TO GET
DEMOCRATS TO CRACK AND IN
NANCY PELOSI HAS MORE THAN MET
HIS MATCH.
>> NO ONE SHOULD EVER
UNDERESTIMATE THE SPEAKER AS
DONALD TRUMP HAS LEARNED.
>> THE DEAL THAT HE ACCEPTED
TODAY IS IDENTICAL TO ONE
SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM FLOATED TWO WEEKS AGO, A
DEAL BACK THEN THE PRESIDENT
POLITELY REJECTED, INSISTING HE